[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
so zusammen hier ist Tatort Deutschland
heute ergründen wir nicht nur einen
fürchterlichen Kriminalfall sondern auch
mal wieder die grauen verzehrten und
schrillen Bereiche des menschlichen
warns im Frühjahr 1990 schreibt die
Frankfurter Neue Presse eine blutige
mautserie hält Frankfurt in Atem ein
Serienkiller macht Jagd auf Obdachlose
die Polizei tappt im Dunkeln
im Mai Titel die Bild-Zeitung das
Geständnis des Unheimlichen sechs Morde
immer mit dem Hammer immer auf den Kopf
immer Befehl aus dem Jenseits und die
Geschichte dahinter die erzählen wir
euch jetzt ich bin Toni Heyer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir wir sind also im Jahr
1990 Frankfurt am Main gilt schon als
die Finanzmetropole in Deutschland aber
noch gibt es nicht so viele imposante
Hochhäuser wie man es jetzt heute kennt
immerhin ist der markante Messeturm
schon im Bau er wird im Oktober 1990
eröffnet aber schon damals hat Frankfurt
auch seine Schattenseiten rund um den
Bahnhof beherrschen Drogensüchtige und
Obdachlose das Bild und in diesem
Frühjahr 1990 sind es noch mehr
Hilfsbedürftige als sonst denn gerade
ist ja die DDR kollabiert monatelang
zogen Zehntausende gehen Westen und
mussten untergebracht werden in
Frankfurt leben deshalb mehrere tausend
Obdachlose und auf den Straßen von
Frankfurt am Main beginnt im Winter 1990
eine der brutalsten Mordserien in der
jüngeren deutschen Geschichte am zweiten
februar um 2 Uhr morgens findet ein
Wachmann in den Arkaden in der
weiß-frauenstraße einen Toten
dem 43 Jahre alten Obdachlosen
Hans-peter s Spitzname peterchen wurde
der Schädel eingeschlagen und zwar bis
zur Unkenntlichkeit wie die Frankfurter
Neue Presse recherchiert lebte
Heinz-Peter s seit drei Jahren auf der
Straße er galt als Einzelgänger meidet
andere Obdachlose und schon wenige Tage
später gibt es den nächsten Mordfall in
der Frankfurter Innenstadt am 7 februar
1990 wird in der Nacht der 22-Jährige
Kurt h mit schweren Kopfverletzungen in
der Friedberger Anlage aufgefunden das
ist ein Parkgelände die Polizei
ermittelt das Haar attackiert wurde
nachdem er aus seinem Schwulenclub kam
an diesem siebten Februar lebt er noch
aber zwei Tage später stirbt cortan an
den schweren Kopfverletzungen weil Haare
muss sexuell war aber nicht obdachlos
sie die Kripo in dieser Phase erstmal
noch kein direkten Zusammenhang zwischen
den Fällen
erst am zweiten April schlägt der
unbekannte Täter buchstäblich wieder zu
an einer Bushaltestelle unweit des
kunstmuseumsschirm wird der
Stadtstreicher Helmut R mit tödlichen
Kopfverletzungen aufgefunden ein
Busfahrer sieht den 32-Jährigen auf der
Bank des rathaushäuschens liegen er soll
dort schon seit Wochen nachts geschlafen
haben
aufgrund einer Zeugenaussage wird ein
paar Tage später ein Phantombild
erstellt daraufhin nimmt die Polizei
sogar einen Verdächtigen im Frankfurter
gallusviertelfest aber der hat ein Alibi
gut vier Wochen darauf am 4 mai 1990
geht die Mordserie weiter
diesmal trifft es den 46 Jahre alten
Obdachlosen Hans-peter m er wird im Park
obermain-anlage mit einem Hammer
geschlagen
wieder schlug der Täter so erbarmungslos
zu dass das Blut Meter weit spritzte der
hammermörder scheint jetzt in einer Art
Rausch zu sein schon einen Tag später
tötet er wieder diesmal gleich zwei
Obdachlose in kürzester Zeit werden an
der Eschenheimer Anlage Engelbert geh
und Nicola Z erschlagen beide haben auf
Parkbänken geschlafen als ein Passat am
frühen Morgen das Blutbad bemerkt atmet
Engelbert geh noch aber er stirbt später
im Krankenhaus Frankfurt ist
mittlerweile ein Aufruhr überall in der
Innenstadt haben Obdachlose Angst um ihr
Leben zum Teil bilden sie Nachtwachen
oder patroullieren sogar in Streifen um
einfach aufeinander aufzupassen
die Polizei schickt blockvögel aus die
sich als Obdachlose ausgeben sie bildet
außerdem eine Sonderkommission mit dem
politisch wenig korrekten Namen Berber
mehr als zwei Wochen lang hält der
Mörder still aber am 20 Mai passiert
wieder etwas Entsetzliches in Frankfurt
am Main der schwule Brasilianer anders
und es verabredet sich mit einem
unbekannten zum Sex im Gebüsch dort wird
er niedergestochen er flüchtet schwer
verletzt auf eine Bank dorthin folgt ihm
der Täter und schlägt den 32-Jährigen
mit einem Hammer Tod bevor das Grauen
auf den Straßen der Stadt endet muss
noch ein Mann sterben am 22 Mai wird der
Obdachlose Heinrich oh an einem
Wohnblock unweit des Weins attackiert
der brutale Mord macht so viel Lärm dass
ein Anwohner die Polizei ruft er sieht
einen kleinen dicken Mann davonlaufen
wenig später fassen Beamte eben diesen
Mann an der U-Bahn-Station
Konstablerwache gute zehn Gehminuten vom
Tatort entfernt der Mann trägt einen
Schlosser Hammer bei sich und in einer
Plastiktüte ein blutverschmiertes Messer
die Polizei hat den unheimlichen
hammermörder gefasst er heißt Arthur
Gatter die Serie ist vorbei
warum haben sie die Männer ermordet
ja nicht mehr schlafen seit Jahren kann
ich nicht mehr schlafen weil
da ist diese Stimme sie sagt ich soll
sie töten töten warum haben sie immer
nachts gegen ein Uhr gemordet naja ich
habe kein Auto ich muss ja kurz nach
eins mit der letzten U-Bahn nach
Bornheim
der hammermörder ist gefasst aber seine
Irrsinns hatten die sind nur schwer zu
fassen außerdem müssen sich die Behörden
fragen lassen ob man Arthur Gatter an
einem entscheidenden Punkt hätte stoppen
können aber lernen wir ihn erstmal
kennen Mirko
autogatta wird am 24 März 1940 im
oberschwäbischen Ravensburg geboren die
Eltern leben getrennt der Vater hat ein
starkes Alkoholproblem die Mutter ist
Putzfrau in seiner Schulzeit gilt der
Junge Arthur als unauffällig aber er
leidet unter Angststörungen er hat einen
besten Kumpel namens Dieter nach der
Schule macht Arthur eine Ausbildung zum
Elektroinstallateur und danach erfüllen
sich Arthur und sein bester Freund
Dieter einen Traum sie gehen nach
Australien und reisen dort von Stadt zu
Stadt zwischendurch aber irgendwann gibt
es Zoff
als jungen Männer nach Deutschland
zurückkommen sind sie fertig miteinander
es lässt sich heute nicht mehr
rekonstruieren ob Artur und Dieter
einfach nur beste Freunde waren oder ein
Liebespaar aber fest steht nach der
Trennung entwickeln sich Arthurs
Angstzustände zu einer ernsten
psychischen Erkrankung in die er über
die Jahre immer tiefer hineinrutscht
Arthur arbeitet als Elektroinstallateur
im Ausland auf Großbaustellen im Nahen
Osten Freundschaften aus dieser Zeit
sind nicht bekannt einzig seine Mutter
besucht Gatter wenn er mal in
Deutschland ist in den 80er Jahren wird
seine psychische Erkrankung aktenkundig
Nachbarn zeigen ihn an weil er Scheiben
einschlägt und Dreck im Treppenhaus
verteilt ihm wird seine Wohnung im
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel gekündigt
von 1987 an hat er Schlafstörungen und
hört Stimmen ein Jahr später wird er
festgenommen weil er Autoreifen
aufschlitzt er wird in dieser Zeit auch
psychiatrisch begutachtet
man attestiert ihm Schizophrenie hält
ihn aber für ungefährlich Gatter ist
mittlerweile arbeitslos er irrt durch
die Frankfurter Innenstadt er schreibt
würde Briefe an Politiker und den Papst
er wirft Müll aus dem Fenster und die
Stimmen die werden immer schlimmer sie
befehlen ihm schließlich Männer auf der
Straße zu ermorden in Verhören versucht
Gatter später seinen Wahn zu beschreiben
zu seinen Mordopfern haben ihn Zeichen
geführt Wegweiser quasi oder Symbole auf
den Schlafsäcken als er schon zwei Morde
begangen hat im Februar 1990 steht Artur
Gatter vor Gericht und genau das ist der
eine Moment in diesem Fall der im
Rückblick so Schicksal schwer ist ein
verzauster steht schlafloser Arthur
Gatter erscheint mit ihrem Blick vor dem
Richter weil er Leitungen zerschnitten
und Autoreifen aufgeschlitzt hat
währenddessen sucht die Polizei aber
diesen Doppelmörder weiß gar nicht dass
sie ihn eigentlich schon vor sich haben
und dieser ahnungslose Richter der muss
jetzt entscheiden wie gefährlich Gatter
ist und ob er in Haft soll den Gericht
liegt das psychiatrische Gutachten vor
dass es schon über den Angeklagten gibt
gatta wird freigesprochen und im Urteil
wird festgehalten dass er keine Gefahr
für die Öffentlichkeit darstellt
wenige Monate später verhört die Polizei
genau den gleichen Arthur Gatter als
achtfachen Mörder die Vernehmungen sind
sehr gründlich und dauernd Stunden
Gatter gesteht laut dem Beamten wirkte
erleichtert endlich kann er alles
loswerden in Bild Frankfurt steht am 23
mai 1990 der Mann einen Meter 70 groß
auffallend stämmig wasserblaue Augen
antwortet ruhig auf alle Fragen aber oft
wird sein Blick seltsam leer er spricht
von einem Sendungsauftrag und von einer
Stimme die ihn aus dem Jenseits
gesteuert hat
in dem Artikel wird auch
Gerichtspsychiater Reinhard redhart
zitiert Gatter fühlt sich vermutlich als
Rächer als Vollstrecker gegenüber einer
sozialen Randgruppe der er die
Lebensberechtigung abspricht ein anderen
mal sagt Gatter er habe die Morde nur
widerwillig begangen er habe wenigstens
versucht seine Opfer mit dem ersten
Schlag zu töten damit sie nichts mehr
spürten Artur Gatter wird in die
gerichtliche Psychiatrie in Gießen
überstellt 70 km nördlich von Frankfurt
und hier entzieht er sich allen anderen
verhören und einem Prozess denn am 12
dezember wird er tot in seiner Zelle
aufgefunden
er hat sich an einem Dachfenster mit
einer Mullbinde aufgehängt der Mann der
seine Befehle aus dem Jenseits erhielt
und die Morde nach dem u-bahn-fahrplan
beging er nimmt seine Motive und
Gedanken mit ins Grab aber Mirko ich
finde aus solchen Fällen können wir uns
auch selber einen reinmachen ich meine
wie viele Fälle hatten wir hier schon im
Podcast wo Leute sich in ihrer
psychischen not alleine fühlten ja und
das waren wirklich viele Leute die in
ihrer Kindheit selber traumatisiert
wurden sexuell oder mit brutaler Gewalt
oder Menschen die ihre Art zu lieben
verstecken mussten oder eben einfach
Menschen mit schweren psychischen
Problemen ich hatte ein paar Zahlen
gefunden und zwar zeigen Studien dass
die Taten von Gewalttätern zu 15 Prozent
durch psychische Erkrankungen erklärbar
sind also wenn man alle Gewalt hatten
zusammen nimmt zum Beispiel leichte
Körperverletzungen Randale
Sachbeschädigung bis hin zu schwersten
Gewalttaten
wenn man Mord und Totschlag betrachtet
ist die Rate von psychisch Kranken
erheblich höher Schätzungen von Experten
gehen von 50 bis 90 Prozent aus ja und
das heißt im Umkehrschluss natürlich
nicht dass wir vor Menschen mit
psychischen Krankheiten Angst haben
müssen oder sie sogar wegsperren müssen
dass natürlich auf gar keinen Fall zeigt
einfach nur wie wichtig es ist dass
Menschen mit psychischen Erkrankungen
Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wird und dass
man diese Krankheiten ernst nehmen muss
und den Menschen eine Chance geben muss
diese Krankheiten zu behandeln ja also
auf jeden Fall ich meine wenn wir die
jetzt alle wegsperren würden wo können
wir dahin ich meine ich bin selbst ich
habe selbst psychischer Erkrankungen und
bin noch nie auf die Idee gekommen
jemanden umzubringen ich glaube das
dürfen wir auch nicht verallgemeinern
das psychische Krankheit gleich
Gewalttäter ist das ist absolut nicht
der Fall und wie du auch gesagt hast es
geht eigentlich viel mehr darum oft
haben diese Menschen gar niemanden der
sie unterstützt und der ihn auch hilft
zum Beispiel diese das Thema
aufzuarbeiten oder ihn einfach auch mal
ein positives Gefühl gibt und sie
annimmt so wie sie sind und ihn nicht
das Gefühl gibt mit dir stimmt was nicht
und ich glaube das ist unsere Aufgabe
als Gesellschaft da mehr aufeinander
zuzugehen aber das wird in unserer
Gesellschaft als so oft vergessen und
diese Menschen werden dann mit ihren
Problemen allein gelassen weil sie sich
absondern weil sie zu Eigenbrötlern
werden und halt dann kein Teil der
Gesellschaft mehr sind das macht es
wahrscheinlich umso schwieriger naja und
damit sind wir am Ende unserer heutigen
Ausgabe angelangt wir danken Euch ganz
herzlich dass ihr wieder mit dabei wart
wenn Ihr Feedback Fragen oder sonstige
Kritik habt dann schreibt uns gerne per
Instagram oder per Mail die Links dazu
haben wir euch in die schauen uns
gepackt und wir freuen uns natürlich
auch wenn ihr uns eine Bewertung
hinterlasst eure Toni und euer Mirko
Skript Stefan Netze Band Schnitt und
Aufnahme Toni Haier Postproduktion
weight watch Studios München für den
heutigen Fall haben wir Artikel aus Bild
Frankfurt genutzt sowie eine sehr gute
Zusammenfassung der Frankfurter Neuen
Presse